hello everyone welcome to comic-con 2022
where i get to introduce you to a super
cool book that's becoming a movie soon i
have the team behind ski weekend with me
right now first congratulations and i'm
so excited for what you guys have on the
horizon thank you we're so excited to be
here it's my first comic con so
here under great circumstances you have
a very very exciting weekend ahead of
you i and i can give you tips i will
give you more tips beyond just going to
brian's 24 for every single meal you eat
here sounds awesome they should sponsor
us so first i need to ask you to do a
synopsis of your book just in case
anyone out there does not know what ski
weekend is just yet yeah no problem so
we pitched it as the breakfast club
meets the live so it's six teens one dog
on the way to a ski trip they get
stranded in the mountains and it's a
story of who lives and who dies okay so
my big question for writing that book is
we see a lot of books and movies and
shows that are survival thrillers are
there any survival thriller do's and
don'ts that you kind of pinpointed
things you've seen in other shows and
things like that where you're like i
want to do that and things that you
wanted to avoid yeah well so i would say
the number one
survival thriller
like do not do is leave the car
which unfortunately when you write a
book to survive a thriller and you have
to have action the teens actually do
have to leave the car
otherwise you won't have a story but i
would say if you are driving a tahoe or
on a mountain ski trip and you get
stranded stay in the car much better
chance of surviving so i think about
this a lot with just about everything i
watch and read and this happened here i
love when stories make me wonder how
would i fare in this particular
situation i'm sure you've thought about
it having written the book i don't know
about you two miles but what would you
do if you were in this situation
actually to get more specific with it
what would be your greatest asset that
you would bring to the group so you
could survive but then what would you
what would your biggest flaw be that
might screw you all over i would say my
greatest asset is i intermittent fast
every day so that could probably prove
crucial while i'm stuck out there in the
wilderness right so i'm already used to
not eating for 18 hours a day so i'll be
good eating on a little bit and trying
to conserve some energy
that's a really good answer i cannot do
that i like to eat i'm doing it right
now starving he hasn't had breakfast yet
um for me i think so there's a character
in the book one of my favorite
characters his name is hunter and he's
kind of like the survival the survival
expert and he says and i learned this i
did so much research in writing this
book and now the screenplay but he says
the number one most important survival
skill which is true which i learned is
morale so i think i would hopefully do a
good job of trying to cheer people on
keep people positive optimistic maybe
tell a couple of fun stories to keep
people entertained and distracted but i
was actually really surprised to read
that i would have thought like making a
fire or you know something else it is a
more like physical skill but actually
it's morale people who when you start to
get like depressed or negative or down
that's when you start to make mistakes
and things go awry you make me feel more
valuable because with every single
survival thriller i watch or read i
always say to myself it's about time you
learn how to like build a fire or even
like to cook the most basic food but i
never do that i can help with the morale
though yeah so i am useful i don't think
i can make a fire to be honest if i was
in the wilderness i don't think i could
do it but
my morale would be high i'd stick with
it okay we we've got the most valuable
traits here really we're going to be
fine
miles for you can you walk us through
the acquisition process a little bit
because this is an especially big deal
for you this is going to be your first
feature as a producer your first feature
for your company so why this particular
story you know i think it's very
unorthodox the way but i guess that's
hollywood nothing's a blueprint of how
to do it i actually knew leonie through
my dad um she was a lawyer on a previous
deal he had done like 10 12 years ago
yeah
and we just met and i read the book and
i really fell in love with it i thought
it'd be the perfect thing to do as my
first feature i love the story and i
also love working with hard-working
talented people like herself and i just
thought all the pieces were put together
in the right way and we should give it a
shot what about for the company itself
because i mean this might be overstating
it but your first feature can sometimes
like define what people come to expect
for you in the long run so what
qualities of ski weekend are you excited
to define your company's start in a
sense i think for me something that i'm
really working with in my company is
mostly thrillers and i think this one's
great because i love aya i've always
been very into all young adult movies
and books and i think to combine both
those things is exciting for me because
my passions always lied in why a stories
as well as trying to bring the thriller
aspect obviously with the heritage and
working with my doubt on this project i
think that just lined up to be the right
thing having learned from your dad what
specific things about him as a producer
do you plan to adopt in your own way of
going about making things i think it's
something that he did when he became a
producer and i'm going to do it that i
did myself and also learning from him is
being a former professional athlete i
think the most important thing that he
stresses to me is just to really grind
and work hard and and take no time off
and like i said earlier about the way
that i acquired it but there's no
blueprint to how to get a movie from the
book to the screen you just have to as a
producer do everything you can and just
keep working to put the pieces together
and i'm excited to do that i think it's
such a great story and it's it's worth
telling i know that you're not this far
in the process yet but thus far is there
any like tactic you've used to further
this project along that's just you know
something really out of left field that
you didn't expect to do but it's helpful
for you now i think what's most helpful
for me is the passion like i would never
want to work on anything that i'm not
passionate about that i don't believe
that would be a great movie or something
that i wouldn't want to see myself like
if this was a movie and i wasn't working
on it i would love to see it so i just
think if i could bring that passion into
every pitch or meeting and as we start
to go out to actors and actresses just
really show them how much i believe it
and obviously leonie believes in it too
after writing it and now that we're
working on the script it's really good
too so i think just entering every
meeting with as much passion behind the
project as possible is not i wouldn't
call it left field but that's probably
my tactic i i would add too i think
there's something really unique about
miles and oren both coming from like the
world of being professional athletes to
now being producers they really like
i've noticed it and working together
they really care about it's weird to
call myself talent but like the creator
or the talent
they really care about you know that
person having a say in the story and
involvement and i think that that is
really rare i do have a lot of friends
and colleagues that are writers as well
young adult authors you know adult
thriller authors and it's like they sell
the project and then it's you know hands
off they never hear about it again i
asked them what's going on i have no
idea
you know once i sold it i've never heard
from them again maybe it doesn't get
made whatever it's like they don't they
have no skin in the game afterwards and
i feel like this has been such an
amazing experience i feel like i'm in
such good hands and i don't know if
that's like from being an athlete or
that experience but they just really
care about the creator and my input i
think for me personally obviously being
a first-time producer and being new to
this i didn't want to be the type of
person that takes your vision and tries
to make it my own because it's not it is
your vision it's just my job as the user
to make it come to life so if i didn't
include you in every step whether it be
someone to help you write it or when we
go out to an actor or a director like
it's not really coming from my eyes or
my brain it's coming from yours and we
have to work together or else it would
completely change the story so you are
you're the screenwriter on this yeah i
wasn't at first no i wasn't at first
what was that process like why why were
you not going to be originally and now
that's not the case anymore so it's
actually so i think i so i did write a
screenplay a long time ago and i
actually filmed a short with my brother
um so i've always really been interested
in it and i did mention when we first
like were in the acquisition phase they
said i really would love to screenwrite
but i also want to be involved as a
producer and orrin of course you know
he's like very wise and very sage he's
like i think you know this is your first
adaptation maybe like let's keep you on
the producer creative side but i don't
know about the screenwriting like we'll
see how that goes that might be a lot
for you to chew off and then as we
started going out the feedback we got
was everyone loves the story and falls
in love with it but in hollywood people
want to see a screenplay to kind of know
like what it's going to look like pacing
wise and i just randomly i think i just
woke up and was like i'm gonna yeah just
give it a stab and you've done such a
great job i think that maybe we cut out
a couple pages and then yeah it's really
long and then we'll be good to go but
i'm actually i'm having a tough time too
because i love it so much i don't even
know what to cut out yet it's so good
but we'll we'll get there soon shortly
after this comic con i feel like that's
always the toughest part this early on
is paring things down but it's important
i get it
all right so you already brought up
casting and again i know that's a little
ways into the future but what are some
of your priorities in terms of upholding
what's in the source material but then
qualities of the character that you
think there's great opportunity in
finding an actor who could maybe bring
something different to the role that we
don't know from the book
yeah i mean i think where we're at right
now especially with casting this is so
exciting because there is so much young
adult and i mean like young adult but
also like in their 20s actors right now
more than ever in hollywood and we just
think we've gone through the list of
people that we'd want yeah and it's
great because you have a melting pot of
a cast of six people in a car and i just
think that that's really obviously with
any survival story it's all about what
happens and who lives and who dies but
really like the core of what makes this
such a great story is their inter
dynamics in the car so i think that
definitely one or two big names then you
never know we can have an emerging star
come out of this thing too i would love
to have some unknowns that's one thing
we talked about i think it could it
could obviously really emerge a star in
this movie i also think like and we've
talked about this too it's a really
diverse cast which i love we have
chinese american we have hunter who's
black i mean it's it's it's not your
typical cookie cutter so i think that
provides a lot of opportunity for
different actors so i love that aspect
of it and i think we talked about this
too every single character i mean it
took me like 10 years to write the book
so every character is crafted very
deeply they all have like a really
interesting backstory their own views
their own experience i really think and
we've talked like each character would
be a really great meaty role for someone
so it's not like even though sam sam is
the main character sam lakin even though
obviously she's you know the main
character every single role
we want someone who's also going to
bring a lot to you each role all these
kids have so much depth they have so
much history together going to high
school together and they have drama from
past and it's really that's what's so
great about the story is when they're
stuck in a car how those things like
rise and unfold yeah all right two-part
character question for you when you were
writing the book which character changed
the most from like the inception of the
idea from character to the finished book
um
i would say hunter i would say hunter
for sure i was really inspired so when i
wrote the character originally i had a
lot of ideas and i knew he was the
survivalist and all of that but i was
actually really inspired during the um
black lives matter movement because that
happened when i was towards final edits
and i'll never forget this like i love
eva duverny i think she's
incredibly talented and i remember she
was tweeting about black cowboys and
that whole history and i actually i'm a
little embarrassed to admit i didn't
know anything about it like i never
learned about that in high school i mean
i'm old so maybe that's part of it but i
didn't learn about it in school and i
was shocked because i feel like that's
something that we should all know about
i just thought through hollywood you
know
white cowboys that's all you ever saw
and so when i saw that tweet it made me
kind of go back and add more layers to
his character and put that in and i i'm
i'll always be grateful to her for that
because it really opened my eyes and i
think it makes him like his story is
much richer now him being so proud of
his heritage yeah such a great character
and it also helps him being like a
leader like we say in in this situation
yeah she's one of my favorite people in
this industry all right second part of
that question now i don't know that i
don't know her personally but i think
she's unbelievable she is a lovely human
being to interview at least and i just
love the passion she pours into every
single project she makes second part of
that character question so we have
hunter being the one who changed the
most during the writing process for the
book but what about from book to script
which character changed most during that
part of the process no one's changed
yeah i was just gonna say no one's no
one's really changing
that that is the hard part that we're
dealing with right now is who we want to
change a little bit it's pretty faithful
right now but it's a little bloated so
there's nothing wrong with faithful if
that's what winds up serving the screen
well
i mean the most important casting
question i should be asking you is how
are you going about finding the right
dog
no i was just waiting for the dog
question um my dog's interested
yeah i think the dog is probably the
most important member of the cast we
gotta make sure we gotta get a good one
yeah we do i mean look any any store
with a good dog
makes it so much better a plus dog work
in this story
all right so
jumping in to the
i guess the rating of it all because one
thing that i'm especially
curious about especially when it comes
to a young adult book to film adaptation
that you know features death in perilous
situations
how far do you plan on pushing it in
terms of raiding i assume pg-13 is the
plan with us pg-13 is of course the goal
um but with deaths always comes that r
push but i think we're gonna do the best
we can to make a pg-13 i think that
makes sense i i am a little bit of a nut
when it comes to r-rated movies and gore
and all of that but it doesn't really
feel necessary to me at least in this
story there's actually one other thing i
wanted to ask you about you also worked
on the journalism side of things for a
while right and you covered a lot of why
a material
is there anything about your experience
working in that field and covering this
type of stuff that you find influencing
your own work whether it is the book or
the movie version yeah i would say more
of an etiquette thing and i think this
is also through being a lawyer too is i
i firmly believe this like be kind to
people be nice
um i just like i dealt with a lot of
people some were very nice some were not
as nice and i just feel like there's
so much to say for just being respectful
being kind everyone's doing their job
and like no one's better than anyone no
one's bigger than anyone and so i think
like i will always and we've talked
about this too
i hope to always come with a very like
kind humble
attitude to everything that i do
um and i really do think that that's
important i think that recognizing other
people are doing their job doing the
best that they can do and i think for me
it's just the professionalism and the
etiquette plus one to that comment if
only everyone behaved that way it would
be a very lovely industry we're all in
um
what else do i have here for you i don't
want to miss talking about the director
so yeah
when it comes to finding a director for
this project what specific things are
you looking for either in their past
work or in your early conversations with
them that could signal to you that this
is the right creator to bring my story
to screen yeah i mean yeah who goes
first i could just i could shortly go
first for me as that's louder we have a
helicopter
um
that's our next step and that's
something we begin to talk about um i
think it's one of the hardest things but
also like the most satisfying when done
right is to shoot a contained movie
um and i think obviously looking into
the past we'd love to have someone that
has shot a contained movie and done it
well so for me
obviously my outlook is to start there
and then and then branch out from there
so that's the producer yeah the producer
has yeah yours is more yeah as a writer
creator mine's more i would love to have
someone on board who really appreciates
like 90s late 80s 90s horror thriller
someone like
lee janiak who just did the fear street
trilogy i think she's incredible
i do love her i also i mean i know
they're just doing tv but the duffer
brothers someone like that who you can
tell
has the heart and the passion because
this is really
i feel like it's it's not horror but
it's like
a lot of that love that went into those
late 90s movies it's kind of who i
envision so someone who can get there's
a lot of easter eggs there's like the
fun they're having the fun together as
they're driving up i want someone who
can shoot that and can get that feeling
on the screen i like that description a
lot but also plus one for legion
yeah that's amazing um before i have to
let you guys go you already brought up
90s horror and
i know what you're working on now has a
90 slasher vibe and there is there is no
section within a's genre than 90
slashers that appeals to me most so when
you're writing that what specific films
are you looking towards and is one of
them scream i knew that i loved you yeah
so scream is my number one all-time
favorite movie ever
it's not my number one it's my number
two but it's my favorite franchise ever
jurassic park
okay that's a really good one
is a very close second i can't i love
wes craven like my biggest i think upset
in life is i never got to meet him i
just he's amazing he is lovely he was
like
i got to interview him once and it's
like that is a perfect example of when
you should meet your heroes because he
was like the kindest warmest soul in the
world and i was like sitting there
shaking in my boots oh i'm so jealous
yeah i would say scream for sure i
actually we've been talking about um
i've been talking to editor about like
the pitch for it and it's very much
mean girls meets i know what you did
last summer kevin williamson is another
one of my all-time idols and heroes and
i definitely it's got a lot of i know
what you did last summer in it for sure
i don't like that was i'm sold i don't
know what the specifics you're writing
right now but that was the pitch that i
needed to go and read that when it's
ready um i have to let you go but we get
to hang out later so i'm gonna say thank
you for coming by the collider interview
studio at comic-con to everybody out
there please go read ski weekend or
listen to it like i did because
audiobooks are books too check it out
you'll love it i promise we'll see you
soon with more comic-con interviews